the 95 southbound lanes have just  reopened after having been shut down for  most of the day traffic anchor nate  tannenbaum here right now live in studio  joining us with the latest yeah brian  denise so that was one of three fatal  crashes that happened this morning that  one up there at the centennial bowl  there's a fatal crash at charleston and  durango another one on state highway 160  between state highway 159 and mountain  springs again that crash southbound on  the 95 just reopened about half an hour  ago so traffic is moving well there the  earlier crash at charleston and durango  that was cleared about 4 30 this  afternoon the earlier crash on state  highway 160 that was cleared about four  o'clock this afternoon denise